president biden reacting to the written
house acquittal and he is not very happy
about it he put out a statement saying
quote while the verdict in kenosha will
leave many americans feeling angry and
concerned myself included we must
acknowledge that the jury has spoken the
president also urging people to protest
peacefully and as you might remember
president biden tweeted a video last
year labeling kyle rittenhouse a white
supremacist
and if you thought he might apologize
for that come on man yeah don't stand by
your
past comment
to white supremacy
well look i stand by what the jury has
concluded the jury system works and you
have to abide by it
what do you think the the president was
trying to say there i think he should
have just stopped at that because that
was the correct answer and then his
puppet masters get a hold of him and say
joe you really your base is going to
freak out if you don't condemn this
this verdict so they put out this dopey
statement where he's angry all of a
sudden he didn't look angry right there
and then he admits basically high fiving
the jury he says to the press that he
hadn't even followed the trial and then
like what was it last year he says this
guy's a white supremacist he had never
even watched the video of the shooting
you know the difference was donald trump
watched the video of the shooting and
was asked about it in the white house
briefing room and he says you know what
looks like he was running away from guys
fell was violently attacked and shot
those guys in self-defense i want it
investigated it should be investigated
but i think police departments should be
doing that job keeping the streets safe
that was the most honest assessment that
we've heard from a politician yet the
media fact checkers just pinocchio the
hell out of that statement and then that
statement became a lie and where are the
fact checkers with joe biden are they
going to say that rittenhouse is not a
white supremacist they'll never say that
so i've talked about this before the
axis of evil all right you have the
press the prosecutors and the
politicians they get together and they
just create a tornado of lies and
turmoil that rips through a city like a
kenosha leaves death and destruction in
its wake and then everybody else is left
to pick up the pieces kyle's crying the
city is now in debt because they're
places of work are burnt down and the
countries like at each other's throat
over racial animosity meanwhile there's
no black guy involved in the shooting
yet al sharpton releases his statement
today and says you know just another
reminder of you know black americans
being shot no black american was shot by
kyle rittenhouse and that is that's what
people think still to this day can kyle
rittenhouse sue a sitting president for
statements that he made when he was a
private citizen and a candidate that is
what lynn wood kyle rittenhouse's prior
attorney aimed exactly to do
because at that time obviously it was
before he was sitting and bill clinton
taught us that yes you can sue a
president for acts prior to assuming the
presidency i have to point out that you
know to your point
biden used that in a campaign ad to
galvanize support and votes to play into
the lie that you were talking about
earlier that arson and looting and
violence is peaceful protesting that
rioting is peaceful assembly that this
trial was somehow good versus fascism
and racism and white supremacy and the
governor of wisconsin furthered that
today in his statement when he said no
verdict will be able to bring back the
lives lost no verdict and heal the
wounds or trauma experienced by jacob
blake and his family no mention at all
of the sacred duty that jurors hold no
good job to the jury know anything of
that the da's office weighed in and said
certainly issues regarding the privilege
of self-defense remain highly
contentious in our current in our
current times to your point all this is
is a narrative a ball that was being
batted around the nation the entire time
and it was created by and amplified by
the media
elected officials politicians reporters
social media and the like and there has
been absolutely no accountability for it
no responsibility even far after all of
it has been debunked but we're going to
continue hearing that we will never have
the truth brought to light of this trial
it will never be covered fairly no
matter what because this is being
furthered as we just saw by the
president and as we just heard by the
vice president as well so obviously
burning things down doesn't work
destroying businesses vandalism theft
none of that works it doesn't make
anything better if you look at the state
of crime and police departments being
refunded i know we're going to talk
about that later in the show so what can
kenosha do
now well i think kenosha's already doing
it if you pay attention what's happening
in the ground in kenosha the people of
kenosha are coming together they're
rebuilt they've rebuilt their community
they really are working hard to move
past both the shooting of jacob blake
and what in this cal rittenhouse case
but where i take issue with what emily's
saying here is you know this idea that
we can
this idea that we can move beyond it or
the side of the media is not doing a
good job there's a lot of reporters
who've been covering this case from day
one sarah seidner is one of those
reporters who today said when the pres
when she said what joe biden said about
white supremacy that's a lie it was
debunked it was completely debunked and
so there's a number of good journalists
who have been on the ground in kenosha
from when the shooting happened until
this verdict was rendered that have been
covering this case both fairly and
accurately and they're they're worthy of
getting the praise that they they should
for covering this the right way because
if to cover this to cover this trial
correctly you have to cover what's
actually happening in the courtroom and
cover the backdrop in which this court
this case is happening which is a
backdrop in which there for a lot of
americans especially black americans
they believe there's two different
justice systems and until you have lived
have part of that lived experience and
understand why they're upset even though
it doesn't play into exactly what's
happening in the kyle rittenhouse case
you don't understand that right there
was a case in texas i could be wrong so
like last month or one of these high
school kids i think killed someone with
a gun and he was just out on bail the
next day
and people say oh you know there's you
know different levels of justice
i can throw another case right back in
your face it doesn't have anything to do
with race richard this case has nothing
to do with race inside the courtroom you
can make up a theoretical case i mean no
i could talk that's just not true i
could talk about julius jones who was
convicted who was murdered
okay
okay
i know that people forget about this but
jacob blake was a good shoot
right
right you're gonna agree with me the guy
was holding a knife oh oh yeah
it was it was the officers were
exonerated exactly he was shot in the
back oh my god it's so sad because he
was holding a knife trying to kidnap a
woman and her kids that's what police
officers did seven times the doj
determined he was trying to
harm a woman if you're okay with that i
guess you're okay with that all right i
find it ironic though that biden woke up
from his colonoscopy to this verdict his
ass literally got handed to him lawyer
up joe because that that kid better sue
your butt
absolutely and you know what it's
interesting if this were that you were
on the other foot there would be an
impeachment proceeding
no wait president trump
single out
president trump sing what are you
talking about
against central park five there was no
president who went after the central
park five
joe biden singled out a person a citizen
influenced the case called him white
supremacists he i will i will put it on
this biden is probably not in control of
his words or his faculties clearly
somebody else is pushing this stuff and
i do believe he's not following the case
somebody else is doing it but you know
if
the argument about this well you know
nope you know no blacks were shot these
were white men they will come back at
you and they will say activists will say
well they were defending
blacks yeah
do you want do you want those to be your
defenders a pedophile and a domestic
computer do you want that to be your
shield what a stupid argument